let's go uh let's go over to the uk and
talk to george from the uk george where
in the uk are you
george
hello can you hear me yes i can
hi there um yeah i'm sure i'm just
outside of london about an hour away
from london to the west coast
not the most uh glamorous town but uh
still pretty good that's good um i have
a question about um covert restrictions
especially in the post-vaccine world yep
um so countries like the uk and
australia
what we've done is you know once the
majority of the population is vaccinated
especially older people yes we've kind
of had a let it rip approach um and
obviously it's very different in the us
um in the because of the kind of
political situation and the
decentralized system there
but here in the uk yeah a bit of a let
it rip approach um and
i'm not the biggest fan of boris johnson
there's lots of things you know to
criticize him for
but i think this is one thing that he's
got right in the case where you put your
faith in the vaccines
and then you yeah you open up the
economy and you basically let the virus
do its thing
and i think
my understanding is on balance when you
balance health economy
et cetera i think that's the right thing
did you but did you have an opinion on
this approach do you think it's better
to be more cautious
or kind of just let things happen the
answer is different depending on what is
happening at the time there was a moment
where the vaccines were very good at
preventing people from getting sick at
all
but now we have a situation where the
vaccines are better at preventing people
from getting seriously ill and dying on
average remember on average and the
virus is now so transmissible that there
really is no containing it so i think
the right approach changes as the
circumstances on the ground change now
as far as the uk moving in the direction
of removing all coveted restrictions
including masking which remind me is it
in 60 days that that's happening or when
is that happening
that is now happening uh in about 10
days in about 10 days okay when it comes
to that
when you look at you know you guys are
ahead of the us in terms of the omicron
wave you're already well on the decline
if you believe that at this point it is
becoming endemic that omicron has burned
through the population and at least
until next flu season things are going
to be well controlled
it doesn't seem crazy to me to say
listen the vaccines have been available
for a year we have a less severe but
very contagious variant which is still
more serious than a cold but much less
serious than the previous ones
if we can keep the medical system
from being overwhelmed while removing
restrictions at a certain point i
understand that countries are going to
do it and it doesn't seem crazy now if
in the fall
there's a much more deadly variant and
there's a different situation my opinion
might change but
the numbers
point to
me understanding why the uk is doing
what it's doing now
yeah i agree and i think it's it's a
good gamble politically as well because
you have all these
um
you know the opposition last year in the
face of the delta wave we didn't really
do too much and then in omicron we
didn't do
you know we changed hardly anything as
well yes um and you have now you know
the opposition we're calling for
more restrictions further lockdowns and
things like that and now
the
conservative government can turn around
and say
you know we didn't lock down we saved
the economy and we kept the yeah we kept
the country open and yes you know
it's it's a it's a good thing
politically as well as hopefully
health-wise as well as long as it
doesn't backfire yeah hey listen i'm
curious you know how there's all these
uh clever pub names in the uk you know
you've got like the spotted pig and the
herpetic frog and all these different
things
are is there a particularly clever pub
name in your town
not really swindon is very known for its
um uh like railway history so there's
lots of
railway named pubs the steam inn and
things like that nothing too kind of
cheeky uh in swindon it's
all right well we'll see if we can get
something opened up there
hopefully yeah very good all right thank
you so much for the call i appreciate it
thanks david all right wow the george
from the uk what a beautiful phone call
why don't we go next to
um let's go to is it nathan from green
acres florida
hello hello david how are you doing
where is green acres
green acres florida is in palm beach
county it's in between wellington and
lake worth oh so it's sort of like trump
country right
i could drive to trump uh to trump's
mar-a-lago yeah yeah yeah okay all right
that's interesting well what's on your
mind
yeah so
hello i've been watching your show for
years it's a privilege to speak with you
the privilege is mine
i am nathan i am in the city of green
acres i'm a candidate for city council
but recently there's been some drama
which i think relates to national
politics in a way okay so we we know
that the right wing
is going hard on
the cancer culture narrative uh they
think we're they're being censored they
think they're being cancelled anybody
with like two brain cells knows that
that's nonsense you know social media is
constantly pushing like shapiro and all
that stuff
but
recently in a city council meeting the
mayor who happens to be a democrat was
censored by three members who two
republicans and one democrat but i hear
that it's like a democratic name only
okay and i just wanted to share that
because it's interesting he wanted to
just
excuse me
he wanted to dispel a rumor and
they adjourned the meeting and the
footage is on the mayor's facebook page
recorded by
an amazing member of the community in
the crowd i wonder who that is
um and
yeah uh
you know i mean are you originally from
florida
yeah whole life lived that's interesting
because um i don't want to get off the
substance but
the word that i say mayor you say mayor
almost like a horse you know a female
horse m-a-r-e is that a local thing
there
i
i'm not sure i always say mayor
that's interesting
well listen it all sounds like more of
the same you know
they claim the other side is doing that
which they do and it's projection and
we're used to it at this point you know
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah
uh hopefully you know i get in
and i we don't have that censorship and
there's a bit more stability in the
council but until then those three have
the majority because uh the way the
system is there's the mayor the deputy
mayor who's a council member uh a
council member and then the three others
the mayor has no voting power so those
three have a voting bloc and they're
able to essentially censor stop progress
whatever they want to do yes and right
now all three of them are being
challenged uh including by myself
um
and
it's shaping up to be an interesting
race now i wish the media would pay a
little bit more attention to but
all right well nathan giving us the
inside scoop on the politics of green
acres florida nathan i appreciate
hearing from you and we're going to do
our best to keep an eye on
on all of it quite frankly we are going
to follow all of it
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping